من منا او الاحرام من العازبين تحديدا مش
انا وعادل لا يحلم بزفاف رومانسي ليس
الواقع الاقتصادي صعب هذا يصعب المساله
طبعا التضخم باتا يطال القفص الذهبي اصبحت
حفلات وفق اخر الاحصاءات فان تكاليف
الزواج تجاوزت 30 الف دولار بالمتوسط في
عام 2022 ارقام دفعت البعض
للعزوف عن الفكره من اصلها
[موسيقى]
في قسم الاقتصاد زميله سمر الماوسطه اهلا
بك يا سمر صباح الخير صباح الورد صباح
السعاده لمن يريد طبعا لكل المقبلين على
الزواج وان شاء الله هم في هذه الفقره
الله يعينكم
الله يعينهم على التكاليف
دائما ما كانت يعني عامل بخليهم يعزفوا عن
الزواج
اصلا حبيت اسالك عن تاثير التضخم اللي
تؤثر على كل مناحي الحياه على الزواج
وتكاليفه بقديه ارتفعت وكيف مبدئيا هناك
دراسه اجرت هذا النوت حتى تكون الارقام
واضحه انه ارتفع التكاليف الزواج بالمتوسط
عالميا اصبحت اليوم تكلفه العرس تقريبا
مثل ما قلنا بالمقدمه 30 الف دولار هذا
الرقم كان 28 الف دولار العام الماضي وقبل
كورونا كان عشرين الف دولار ففي
50% خلال او اقل شويه خلال هذه الفتره خبر
الحلو انه ان شاء الله هذا الصيف راح تبلش
تتراجع تكاليف الزواج مره اخرى حتى نكون
دقيقين اكثر 7% من الاشخاص العام الماضي
عزفوا عن الزواج او اجلوا فكره الزواج الى
فيما بعد بسبب ارتفاع التكاليف هذا نتكلم
جلوبال احنا عندنا يعني بالعالم العربي
ما تتزوجوا احنا بدنا نعطيهم امل بانه لا
ممكن يعمل
السنه الجايه لما ينزل خلي
معدلات التضخم تتراجع ثانيا الاجيال
الجديده مثل ما قلنا شويه عندها وعي اكثر
احنا كنا بزمنا هوايه نسوي حفلات ونعزم
هوايه ناس هسا هم اكثر يعني يحبوني يعزمون
العقربه مثلا مثلا الدعاوي الكارتات تصير
ديجيتال طب خلينا خلينا هلا نحكي
نصائح ممكن تسهل على العريس والعروس وتخفف
عن جيبتهم اول شيء الميزانيه بالتاكيد
حطوا ميزانيه واستيك لهاي الميزانيه
ارتبطوا بهاي الميزانيه حاولوا ما تخرجون
عن هاي الميزانيه الميزانيه اللي ما تتطرق
انك تتداين هاي واحد اثنين عده مثلا اذا
ما تسويه بالويكند ممكن توفرين 20% من
التكلفه 20% ارخص على النفر بالعرس اذا
كانت ما كانت في ابعدوا عن الويكند ابعدوا
عن الويكند نعم عندك اليوم مثلا تكاليف
الورد العديد يستخدمون ينزجون الورد
البلاستيك مع الورده الطبيعي فهذه من
الاشياء اللي
ورد
ايضا هناك ايضا حديث دائما انه اليوم
خلينا نلجا مش الى القاعات التقليديه
خصوصا في المناطق اللي يكون فيها الجو حلو
هناك توجه الى المزارع الى الحدائق انا
حضرت في تركيا مثلا العام في حديقه في
بارك عام مع انه الاشخاص كانوا مقتدرين بس
حتى كطبيعه وكمنظر وكشي وهي الباركات
نفسها اليوم يعني تاجر هذه هناك ايضا كوست
مش بس على العروس والعريس علينا احنا
الحاضرين اليوم يقول لك في امريكا اللي هم
ما يصرفون على الصالونات هوايه وما يصرفون
على الميك اب اون افريج يكلف اللي يريد
يحضر عرس
يكلف 800 دولار بين الفستان
المراه لا تروحين للعرس اللي انت معزومه
عليه وانت
مكياج اكثر من العروس او مضبطه حالك
روحي الصبايا دائما شكلهم حلو
فستان الزواج ولا هذه الان اصبحت
تاجر فستان الزواج وبعدين يقعد عندك احنا
نقول الكنتور بالخزانه فتره طويله او على
الفاضي كله تصرف فلوس بينا ممكن توفر 70%
اذا تشتري او تاجر لبسه اولى العديد من
العرايس ياجرون لبسه اولى هي اول وحده
تلبسها وتاجرها ليش لا عيب ابدا فالا افضل
من شراء اكيد الفرح حتى البدله الفرح عاده
بتكلف كثير حفله هل في هناك اي نصائح ممكن
تخفف من منطقه التكلفه مثل ما قلنا
البانيو اولا لانه هي اغلى شيء هي تقريبا
يعني
50% من تكلفه الزواج هو المكان الفانيو
فهاي اول شيء يتخفف عليه اليوم هناك ايضا
تكاليف مثل ما قلنا يشترك العروس والعريس
بدل ما يسوي اهل العروس احنا عندنا خصه في
العالم العربي اهل العروس يسوون الخطبه
واهل العريس الزواج ممكن يشتركون بالزواج
بحفله وحده كبيره
يعطيك العافيه والله حابب يتزوج روحه
تزوجوا صيف كيفكم والف مبروك
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات